prosecutors here in Clark County say
they will not seek the death penalty
against Rob Tellis he's the former Clark
County public administrator and this
morning he was back in court Telus is
accused of murdering a review journal
reporter and he finally entered a plea
eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy was there
Robert Tellis pleading not guilty here
in court he's the former Clark County
public administrator accused of killing
review journal investigative journalist
Jeff gearman on September 3rd gearman
exposed problems under the leadership of
Telus including a possible inappropriate
relationship with a subordinate Telus
then lost the Democratic primary Telus
was indicted by a grand jury for murder
the case against him continues to move
forward earlier this week he filed a
court document to hire an attorney he
was previously represented by public
defenders employees at the public
administrator's office were here in
court an emotional moment as they saw
Telus in person for the first time since
his arrest the next court appearance for
Telus is set for November 2nd reporting
at the Regional Justice Center in
downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News
Now